all I'm doing is calling things like
they are the new bachelorette villian
defends himself that was Chad Johnson
and he became virtually an overnight
celebrity after Monday's episode of The
Bachelorette
his name was trending on Twitter thanks
to outrageous moments like this yes Chad
offended Jojo and just about every guy
in the house but justified it all by
saying that he was just being honest now
the scary thing is things might turn
violent here's the teaser for upcoming
episodes it's not a wise decision
this guy is nuts I don't want to be
around a guy that's volatile like that
don't you touch me dude you're gonna die
yeah blood on his hands
yikes now do things get violent or is
that just good editing
well chad is defending himself he writes
on the instagram I'm not violent but I
will stand up for myself being as I like
everyone else do not like being harassed
and bullied we'll have to see what
happens
notably Chad also posted a shirtless
photo of himself on Instagram writing
quote come at me bro well I want to know
what you think is Chad being
refreshingly honest for a reality show
and we're just not used to it
or is he starting drama to steal the
spotlight let me know on Twitter I'm at
Lauren's Eva